- On this episode, I talk about
design changes, what I would do
with $3000 to build my business
and do I like being challenged?
(upbeat hip hop music)
- [Gary] You ask questions,
and I answer them.
This is The #AskGaryVee Show.
- [Gary on book cover]
New York Jets
asking me questions.
- Thanks Seth this is
awesome. So cool.
Hey everybody,
this is Gary Vay-ner-chuk
and this is episode 205 of
The #AskGaryVee Show.
I'm glad we snuck this one in.
With the whole Tyler and
India thing I think we're
out of rhythm of scheduling.
I have not been on a
pace at all with the show.
This is been the dark ages
these last 45 days so
I need to get back on track.
Garrett, thanks for
holding up Facebook Live.
Good to see you guys.
How's that going?
How many views
did we got so far?
- 818 so far.
- Nice. Quick to 1000.
India, it's great to see you.
- Great to see you too.
- How've you been?
- Good.
- All well?
- All well.
- Great. You ready for the show?
- I am. Did you see our montage?
- Let's get into the show.
- I did not watch it yet.
It's great?
- So good.
- Should we?
How long is it?
Good.
- We've done a lot of shows.
Can we put it right here? It has
to be in my channel click out.
Staphon, you know you've
messed this up.
Link it up.
Link this one up.
Got it?
We'll link up our montage.
Oh I'm sorry.
Let's add to our montage.
- Okay.
- Let's get into
- [Both] The show.
- Nice one.
- That was good.
- Nice and solid.
Not too crazy.
Trouty... What is that
like salmon?
Is that like salmon?
Is that a salmon sweater?
- Looks brighter.
- Yeah, okay.
Trouty. Make sure you
put up his handle.
Everybody who is watching
this show go tweet Trouty
nice salmon sweater.
Yeah let's do that,
#nice, put that up Staphon,
#nicesalmonsweater.
Put his handle.
Really funny story about Trouty,
Jon Troutman, I think his handle
is Trouty which is is Mike Trout
the best baseball player in the
world or the second best
baseball player in the world.
Big ups Bryce Harper to most
people that's his nickname and
most people think Trout is him.
Every time Mike Trout hits
two home runs in a game
his Twitter explodes.
(laughter)
Anyway. Let's get
into the show, India.
- [Voiceover] James asks,
"Gary, I want to snap and vlog
"my work but I'm posting sitting
at a desk on my phone and email.
"How can I add
variety in content?"
- Well you got to be creative.
Funny thing about this is
there's a crazy thing guys.
Crazy thing about creating
content both for social media,
both for television,
both for books,
both for magazine articles
it's called talent.
There are plenty of people that
can sit at a desk all day and
produce amazing content because
they're funny, they're clever.
They're imaginative.
They are creative by nature.
So my answer is talent.
James.
You've got to come
up with an idea.
Asking me to give you the
creative pillar is not a good
strategy because
I can tell you that
you could do it all day long.
You can do a whole series on
Snapchat of random websites.
Why don't you just take your
phone while you sit at your desk
and in-between important
things go to StumbleUpon
click a button, random website
show it on the screen and
you audit those websites.
You add your two cents.
Social commentary to every
website on the internet.
You would never have to
leave your desk, ever again.
But are you good enough?
Are you funny enough?
Are you quick-witted enough?
One of the most famous videos is
when I cold called somebody and
tried to sell them an ad
'cause I was good at it.
That's why it was good content.
I just sat at my desk.
I think the answer is too many
people think that you have to
rely on amazing scenery or
having a mix, a different day.
I think my Snapchat
is all the same shit.
It just me in my
face wherever I am.
I'm trying to mix it up.
I eat a banana here and there
and now I go to weird bathrooms.
I'm trying.
Have you seen that yet?
- [India] Yeah.
- Thank you.
I travel a lot.
I think bathroom
culture is fascinating.
- [India] (inaudible)
restaurant bathrooms.
- [Gary] Well there you go.
So there you go.
Why would you
even ask me that?
Hold on let's start
over but you just said--
- [India] There's a difference
between really random creepy
bathroom and you
Snapchatting from it and
then curating a blog
of interesting bathrooms.
- Yeah, super different, India.
Anyway my man, James, anything
can be funny anything to be
interesting it comes
down to the talent.
If you're one that
needs this visual support.
This is a binary question
meaning if you're not good
enough in a mundane similar
situation to create something
that's interesting and
intriguing well then I don't
know you got to get a new job.
Something crazy.
I don't know.
You're stuck.
There certain truths you're gonna
sit at your job and do calls at
your desk it sounds
like regardless.
So instead of saying that the
defense, make it an offense.
It is a mindset.
Unless you're willing to change
your job and travel the world
and have all this great scenery
in the background like
buck up Charlie, James.
And figure it out.
I mean you can take a
whole meme just about,
I could do a whole
thing just on Courtney.
At the front of our.
I could basically make Courtney.
I can basically make
anybody famous if I want to.
(India laughing)
- I mean it is true.
I like to think I'm a
little entertaining.
Sean.
- What is up, Gary?
Sean from Denver, Colorado here.
You can see the beautiful Rocky
Mountains in the background.
My question for you
about negotiation.
What are your best tips for
getting the deal done and
making sure that it's mutually
beneficial for both parties?
- Sean, it's interesting.
Great question.
Thank you for heeding
the call for better video,
better scenery in the background.
I'm sure there's a bunch there
pent up from a month or two ago.
It's funny.
They're one of the same.
I'm very aggressive.
And I very aggressively go
after a person and say look as
quickly as possible I
want you to trust me.
Tell me what you want.
What is in your vested interest?
If I can figure out what that
person wants and first I go with
honesty and you know it's funny
and when somebody is negotiating
with you they don't
want to give you honesty.
And actually I use it as a
tactic to build a relationship.
If I go at somebody and say look
you guys know this with,
some of you know
this with salaries.
It's how I negotiate
almost everything.
I just want to know.
Because by the way, if you say
"Hey, I want to pay VaynerMedia
"four dollars a month," and I want
four dollars a month well then
we just saved a lot of time.
I'm like cool.
Let's do it.
I think my best tactic has
been the same which is
honesty, truth and aggressiveness
to extract the truth
from the other person.
I'm naturally a counter puncher.
In my marketing and
definitely in my negotiating.
What do you want to
happen for how much?
And if I can get them
into a truthful place.
Now one of the keys to my
strategy is drawing
a line in the sand.
When I say to somebody
give me your best offer and
if I can hit, I'll do it.
If they then give me an
offer that I can't do
I have to say no
and I can't move.
It's all grounded in truths.
I think you have to know what
you want and I think you have to
try to extract from the
other person what they want.
And you need to try to make
them feel comfortable that
you're in their best interest.
One thing I do is I point to
my career at this point and let
them know I've done everything
on lifetime value that I don't
need to make much money up
front it's all of the long-term.
I require that for my people.
I require that for my partners.
I just think the right way to
go there is go right at it.
What's going to
get this deal done?
For me, I'd rather leave profit
on the table to get the
deal done quicker.
I think too many want to
guess the higher number.
Let that one $8000 for this.
I think too many people are like
12,000 instead of saying how
much is it going to get done and
Staphon says 7500 if I'm okay
with that because I want 8000
I'm like good, done, let's go.
Speed, movement, trust,
relationships finding a place
where you can trust that
person you're on the same page.
That's how I see it.
- [Voiceover] Nishita asks,
"Gary, how do design changes to
"apps that cause a negative stir
affect brand image or usage?"
- Is this back Instagram?
- [India] Yeah.
- This stuff
happens all the time.
Remember when Uber
changed it's logo?
I think Uber's new logo is
way worse than it's old one.
But that's one man's
subjective opinion.
Even though all four
of you shook your head.
Do you like the
Instagram one better now?
No, no.
- [Garrett] Yeah.
- Yeah, got it.
Me neither but whatever.
Nobody gives a crap.
If anybody still today still
cares about the Instagram design
change then they don't realize
that Instagram is a business and
not a museum.
In the context that I come from
if you're making art that you
want debated for the rest
of time it really matters.
If you are talking about
business everybody complains
about logo changes on
sports teams pro, con,
logo changes of apps pro, con.
It's a fun thing to talk
about but if you noticed I got
bombarded about it on social and
I didn't even answer anybody's
question about it because I
didn't even want to respect the
question because for me from
a business standpoint it has
0.00000 impact on
Instagram's business.
Now the UI and UX if it makes
people stay on it longer, engage
with that it longer, that has
huge impact but the logo itself
as a matter of fact it does
have impact I'm not
pooh-poohing design.
I believe in the design.
For example, I think
I'm using Instagram less.
The first week just because my
eye didn't recognize the logo as
much I hit it less times.
Not even kidding.
But I'm a focus group of one.
I think net-net on a 60, 90,
100 day term, it doesn't matter.
I'm already back to my
normal usage on Instagram.
It can be an issue but
I think a lot of time
press over engages it.
For example, when the Gap
changed it's logo and that was a
whole to do and they changed
back or when people have to do
that a lot of times is
more about the press and the
perception and then the
stock price more so than
what's actually happening
in user behavior.
But sometimes it
could be a change.
I don't over, I think a name and
a logo can always be trumped by
the quality of the product.
Even bad press.
When Uber's getting
all that bad press.
My friends, "I feel bad
what Uber is doing,"
and they're take an Uber
while they're saying it.
I'm a big fan of
actions over words.
All the people that I hate the
Instagram logo but are using it
.3 times more today
than they did a week ago,
what does that then mean?
It's like saying you're moving
to Canada if you don't like the
president and then not moving
which is what basically all of
my extremist friends on the
Republican and Democratic side
have done of the last 16 years.
Everybody moved to Canada during
Bush every move to Canada during
Obama and so far
nobody moved to Canada.
Because you're full of shit.
And that's just a higher
level conversation of the logo.
What does it mean?
I don't know.
A lot of people like to
say things on social media.
I like to know what you actually
do versus what you actually say.
- [India] That's good.
Yeah that put the (smack).
- [India] I think it's
Avica or it's Avici?
- It's Avicii?
- [India] Yes, Avicii's
asking a question.
- Finally. Yes you can
sample my shit.
(laughter)
- [Voiceover] Ivica asks,
"Gary, you challenge the old
"every day. How do you
feel when challenged
"from the young
professionally?"
- Tremendous.
I love to be challenged
more than anything.
I think one of the misnomers
of a cult of personality like
myself is that we all love
yes men and women around us.
I can tell you that look you
get the benefit of being right.
One of things I hate about my
success and I knock on wood
because I don't want to jinx my
success is the longer I have it
and the more that I have the
less I'm being challenged by
the young or the less
experienced or the less winning.
It's very dangerous when
you've accumulated success
that you're not being challenged.
I love challenging people
and I love to be challenged.
What I love most about being
challenged is like 8 out of 10
times that I'm challenged in
something that I really now
I feel like the person is
challenging me for the sake of
challenging me 'cause they're
playing that role 'cause they
think it's going to catch my
attention but then I'm actually
in the game of the argument and
when they look like an idiot and
they're wrong by all standards
it actually makes them lose.
Why I'm painting you that little
picture is when I challenge,
I challenge with substance.
It's funny that I just
talked about presidents.
Politics, healthcare,
macroeconomic issues,
geopolitical issues, terrorism,
health and wellness,
boy, do I not challenge anybody.
Boy, do I do a lot of listening
and when I am at my worst
occasional pontificating about
my opinion on it but boy
you will not see venom.
If we all have brunch and we
start talking about something
I don't know about it's
stunning how quiet I get.
It's just you only see
me in things that I know.
You only see me challenging
things that I know.
Of course, I'm going to
challenge Seth Godin
if I don't agree with him.
Because I know.
I love when somebody challenges
me at this company and outside
this company when I can taste
that they know that they're
talking about because
then you have some real
frictions make diamonds.
I want to get better.
I want somebody to challenge
me but when you're going to
challenge me that TV or direct
mail is better and all you have
is some bullshit from 1984
and you're not a practitioner
anymore and you have
nothing to back it up
you're gonna get eaten up.
I love being challenged.
I want the young to
challenge me all day.
You saw me in the episode
with the 15-year-old girls
for musically, I was listening.
I'm not telling
them they're wrong.
They're in high
school, they're there.
They're like, "All my kids
in my class are on Twitter."
Cool. Respect, wow.
So that's that.
And by the way that is a
focus group of one high school.
It doesn't mean Twitter is now
everybody GaryVee thinks
Twitter is huge in high school.
No, I think it is an interesting
thing to pay attention to
because after that comment
hundred of more emails and
comments of people like yeah
it's true in my high school too.
And by the way, tens, by the way
just to ground you, of like
I don't know what that
girl's talking about.
At my high school nobody's doing
but tens to hundreds, you know?
- [India] Last one.
- Last one.
Joey nice Jets sign.
- Hey Gary Vay-ner-chuk I saw on
one of your videos that you got
asked if you were to build a
company in 2016 today from
scratch what would you pick.
Erase all your followers all the
companies that you have
built up to this date.
You said you would
choose something like Nike.
So my question is at the
beginning stages of your company
what would you do for
your three next moves.
What were your top three
first moves be to help grow your
company and keep in
mind you only have $3000.
What would those three steps be?
- Guys can't get more specific?
- Ads, an expo at a
convention center, inventory,
what would it be?
Let me know, can't wait to hear
your answer and thank you for
including my question
and today's show.
- What is the name?
- [India] Joey.
- Joey, great question.
The truth Joey and everybody who
is watching and so many of you
are emailing me and please
by the way this is a good
opportunity, Staphon, can you
put a little video pop-up you'll
do a little
editing for this one.
Actually put a
picture I don't make you.
#AskGaryVee the search engine.
If you have business questions,
my new search engine
is unbelievable.
All my questions all of my
answers transcribed
all there in the search engine.
So many questions about this and
the truth is Joey you clearly
ask for yourself there so many
things you could be doing for
your apparel business I guess
is why you referenced Nike.
First of all, I said if you're
in apparel the number one thing
I would do it would try to get
Instagram influencers to wear
your product at zero cost all
the way up to $1, $3, $50, $100.
I think influencers
are grossly underpriced.
I think the game is about
exposure and conversion
and I think that too many people
don't really understand how
to run a business.
Make a lot of bad mistakes.
As a matter of fact, I'm super
pumped that "Shark Tank" is now
doing this "After
The Tank" TV show.
I don't know if any of
you have watched it.
But Lizzie loves it.
They're showing people going
out of business because
they grow too fast.
They don't understand.
There's a real
cadence of growing.
It's like anything in life.
You can't get too
ahead of yourself.
You can't go too slow.
You know it's funny, a lot of
people when they start digging
into my content realize
that I'm a real contradiction.
That I believe in very
opposite points of view.
And I think my answer
to your question is
it's a mix of 100 different things.
I couldn't give you, I'm not
going to give you what you want
from this question which is
these three tactical things.
I only give very black-and-white
tactical advice when I actually
have hours to sit down and look
at your business and actually
understand what
I'm talking about.
I don't want to look like an
idiot or have egg on my face so
then I thought about
religious points of view.
For you, you need to
get that shirt and
you need to get
as much exposure.
The same way you hacked your
way on to this show asking a
question now you got exposure.
I saw you put your little
Snapchat logo down there
in the corner.
Some people snapped it,
following you now.
You're looking for exposure.
I think it's a grind.
For apparel
businesses are very hard.
You need distribution,
you need awareness
to me what I would
do is a lot of listening.
I would tell you very honest
answer, Joey, if I were you as
young as you look and
you look great,
nice and young, super fit dude.
Oh India likes it.
(laughter)
What India said yeah.
What?
- What do you want me to say?
No, you look horrible?
- [Gary] No, no.
- [India] Yes he's fit.
- Yes, that's exactly right.
That's right.
He is a fit man.
Right, Garrett?
- Yeah.
- [Gary] Yeah super fit.
- [India] Garrett agrees too.
- Yeah, exactly.
Wasn't a boy-girl thing.
Just is he fit?
I think that one of the things
that scares the living piss out
of me is that a young dude like
you and so many young dudes and
dudettes like you everybody's
just jumping in and
running a business.
You know what I would tell
you to do, actually know what?
I'm going there.
Screw it.
You know what I'm
going to tell you to do?
Shut your business down
and go work for an apparel
company for three years.
Go email every CEO of an apparel
company that's doing over
$5 million dollars a year in
revenue that you respect.
All of them.
Sit down grab a nice shake
right, kale, nice kale shake and
map every single CEO
in the world that has a
$5 million a year or higher
revenue apparel business.
Then to go to LinkedIn and
Twitter and email and
tweet all of them.
And ask all of them for you
to be there chief of staff,
right-hand man and to work
side-by-side with that person
for the next 18 months.
That's what I would do.
Stake versus sizzle.
There's no tactic that
I'm going to tell you on
The #AskGaryVee Show that's gonna
set you up for success and to be
very frank with you and I don't
want to hurt your feelings Joey
and I have a lot of respect for
you and is hurting everyone's
collective feelings my intuition
is somebody building a really
big business in the apparel
space is not going to rely on
one their tactics being
asking a business guru
for advice tactically.
So, I would take that 3000 bucks
and save it so that you can live
with 17 roommates while you work
for Carol Thompson and her
$9 million a year apparel
business and watch it up
close and personal.
India do it one more time
and I don't do this for
humble bragging.
I think it's important because a
lot of you know India and she's
been our eco-system, one more
time, four years in Vayner?
- Almost four years.
- India, three weeks in my
inbox, say it one more time
different than you thought.
- Totally.
- India learned more, it's only
three weeks but just different.
Just different.
And you can't buy that.
India sat here and all god
damn shows with you guys.
India's written a ton of stuff.
Has probably consumed way
more of my voice than she
would ever want to.
Yet in a 10 day period
being in my inbox,
being close to the sun,
she gained more context.
I wouldn't say learned
but holy crap, what?
Yes.
And that's why so many of you
are jumping to run a business
and I'm a natural
good businessman.
A lot of you don't
have as much
natural entrepreneurial
DNA as I do.
I think you need to learn from
the hip and I think the biggest
mistake is you'd rather go get
and this is a different piece of
advice for a lot of the
college kids that
I've reached through
that one video.
You'd rather go get that
job at $63,000 at the Gap
and be number 17,000
even though your ambition
is to run your own fashion brand
versus making no money teaming
up with 19 roommates living that
ghetto lifestyle but being the
right-hand person but remember
if want to start your own
fashion brand isn't it much
better to be very close to a
person that's got a
$3 to $5 million a year business
because that's going to
be your first step.
Even if you're at
the right hand of the
CEO of Nike or Adidas or
Under Armour or Coach
that's not the company
that you're going to build.
You're going to learn
Corporate America skills.
I'm just completely pissed
with the lack of,
(sigh) it's a lack of patience.
It's much cooler to say your
founder of the company,
"Hey bro, what you do?"
"Oh, I have my own brand.
"I'm an entrepreneur.
I'm crushing it."
And Joey I'm not picking on you.
This is a general statement.
"I got my own business."
That's sexy.
"I'm an entrepreneur."
That's a rockstar.
That's cool right now.
Not as cool as "Hey
bro, what are you up to?"
"Oh, I'm the Junior assistant
for Rikki Thompson
for her underwear brand."
What? You went to
college for that?
But I'm telling you right now
the person with the humility and
the patience to the second
scenario is going to
win every time.
99 out of 100 times.
It's just what's
going to happen.
I'm glad I got to say that.
I'm glad I came out.
It is true.
It is super true.
And when shit hits the fan and
it will and people can't raise
money and it's not that easy.
3000 bucks is not a lot of
money to start a business.
Too much dreaming right now.
Question of the day:
What have you been up to?
I feel like I really it's been a
couple of months here
It's feels like I'm out of rhythm.
I'm going to read every single
response to the comments here.
Thank you so much for
all the love on DailyVee.
It feels like everybody is
really feeling what is
going on over there.
I appreciate that and
I hope you are well.
I miss you.
We're getting close
to the summertime.
It's gonna be great.
India, good job.
Staphon, Garrett
thank you so much.
Facebook Live.
You keep asking questions,
I'll keep answering them.
What's up guys?
Hope you enjoyed the show.
Please do I get to
link it up anywhere?
Is it in here or
is it down below?
Is it in print or in my video?
- [Staphon] It'll be down there.
- It's here down to my left.
Right here, there's a button
for them to subscribe
to my YouTube video?
Yeah it's that
little buggy thing.
That's right guys, click this.
That's right, use that.